[Müzik]
Evet
Merhabalar arkadaşlar Gerçekten çok
heyecanlııyım hani öncelikle onu
söyleyeyim Aslında ilk tek konuşma
olmasına rağmen ve Hani hep derler böyle
sahnede Aslında son konuşmayı alarak bir
çok böyle paslar açmayı düşünüyordum ama
sağ olsun herkes bütün taktiklerimi
çaldı 1 taktiğim ekibi alkışlatmaktı sağ
olsun Emrah kardeşim onun işi halletti
kızımı sahneye çıkarmak taktiği vardı
hocam oraya halletti ama bugün biraz
size arkadaşlar benim Bu etkinlikte
galiba kültürü ve birkaç kişi dışında
Fethiyeli olan konuşma yapmak kısmet
olan fethiyenin tedx hikayesini Ee
Aslında fethiyeler olarak katılan
birisiyim kendi Hayat hikayemi
anlatacağım daha önce teknik konuşmaları
yaptım ama bugün size de bir genç
Fethiye 50 mesajı odur arkadaşlar yani
kendinizi değil dinleyenlere mesaj
veriyorsunuz derler Ben de burada size
ben Sizin yeriniz olsaydım ben de bu
arada İlkokul ve Ortaokulu Fethiye'de
okudum ve bu yüzden belki sizin
alacağınız mesajlar benim Bugün
yapacağım sunumlardan bazı hayatınızı
değiştirebilir Aslında dileğim bu ve
kendi Fethiye camide ilk kez anlatacağım
bu ve büyük ihtimal son kez olacak şimdi
Tom bir hikayesi var Çok güzel bir
hikaye duyan var mı bu Mark twai'nin
kitabı Tom sawyer'in Maceraları okuyan
var mı Süper Çok sevindim süper
Arkadaşlar bu literatöre geçmiş bir konu
Songül effect diye geçiyor şurada
gördüğünüz sarı şapkalı çocuk aslında
biraz yaramaz bir çocuk Hatta
arkadaşlarıyla bir adaya gidiyorlar
yanlışlıkla Orada kalıyorlar çıkmıyorlar
bulunamıyorlar Anneleri
işte arıyorlar arıyorlar alıyorlar Artık
devlet geliyor Bütün Köyü ayağa
kaldırıyorlar galiba çocuklar öldü
diyorlar çocukların mezar Eee işte
cenazeleri yapılıyor mezarları yapıyor
çocuklar geliyor böyle bir roman
Hatırladınız mı insanlar cenazedeyken bu
kadar yaramaz çocuklar ne kadar yaramaz
olabilir öyle iki üç taş atmadan
bahsetmiyoruz şimdi Mark ceza alıyor
ceza şu; şurada gördüğünüz çitleri
boyamak ve bu ceza yaramazlığı
karşısında ceza olarak veriliyor cezayı
yapmaya başladığında boyarken kurtuluş
yok bütün arkadaşlara oyunları oynuyor
bir tek kendisi ceza aldı Böyle mesela
Ceza gibi işler olabilir mi kendinizi
düşünün hayatınızı düşünün işte bakalım
bu soğuyor ne yapmış arkadaşlar diyor
gelin diyor futbollu her gün oynarsınız
çok güzel bir hikaye Burada gördüğünüz
gibi bu insanlar buradan ilham alıyorlar
işte benim küçük tomsal birim de bu Bu
benim arkadaşlar ve bu işte Fethiyeli
çocuk aslında biraz yaramaz Ben ona
bağlayacağım çünkü Bence bu hikaye
buradan şey yapıyor ve üstünde de
gördüğünüz gibi burası sevgili Rahmetli
babamın Oteli diyeyim üstünde Eröz Otel
yazıyor Görüyor musunuz
Oteli işletiyorum Fethiye'de olmak
istedim Aslında bu babamı kaybettikten
sonra oteli ben işletmeye başladım ama
hikaye şöyle başlıyor Yani bu Otel Eröz
Ercan Özcan Babam ve Aslında Dedem Bir
Köy Enstitüsü mezunu Köy Enstitüsü bugün
geçti birkaç şeyde Yani bu profil nasıl
olmuş derseniz Yani bir Fethiyeli sana
şaşırıyor Çünkü nasıl böyle işte işler
yapabilmiş gibi arkadaşlarım hepsi
konuşuyorlar Bence biraz dedemden gelen
bir hikaye var köy enstitülerini
inceleyeyim ben özellikle eğitimci
olaraktan dedemin Belki duymamıştır Ama
bu bölg Antalya Aksu diye hatırlıyorum
buraları bir yerde yazıyor mu bilmiyorum
ama Aksu Aynen Aksu köy enstitüsü'nde Ee
aldığı bir ders var ve ee Hasan Yılmaz
diye geçiyor günlükbaşı İlkokulunda ilk
müdürü kendisi kendi Dedem dededen çok
vakit geçirdin Ee Hatta işte vefat etti
99 senesinin son Ee tatilde okulum
açılmadan evvel Ee çok ciddi bir süre
yaylada 8 belki bilirsiniz temel
yaylasında son işte iki hafta orada
geçirdim ve arkadaşlar İnternet yok
internet zaten o kadar yaygın değil
televizyonda çekmiyor
Sonra bir sonraki geliyordu telefonla
ama klasik telefonda Hani Dünya yerinde
mi diyor öğrendiğimiz bir dönemdi iki
hafta geçirdim kendisiyle ve yani çok
etkileyici bir konu bu Ukrayna hikayesi
Bende çok fazla Eee emeği var öyle
söyleyeyim Bu da babam dedem ve ben bu
da 99 vefat etmeden vefat etmeden birkaç
hafta önce otelde oynadığımız kağıt
oyunları şimdi bakın böyle hani bir
eğitim diyorum bir oyun diyorum dediğim
gibi bu hikayeyi ilk kez anıyorum yani
bunda Fethiyeli gençler anlatıyorum Hani
o yüzden çok özel fotoğraflar
hazırlamaya çalıştım Burada gördüğünüz
gibi oteldeyiz Akşahin bir araya
gelmişiz böyle oyunlar oynuyoruz Bunlar
mesela
çalışıyordum Annem de rahmetli işte hep
şaşırırdım sınavdan çıktığımızda
çıkardım böyle anne gerçekten 13 tane
yaptım ha Yazık çocuğa işte 40 tane
matematikten Hayır kalem dokundurmadım
13 tane yaptım
kendimce testi zorlaştırıyordum kalem
dokundurmadan 13 tane çözebilmek tamam
mı Çünkü zaten full çekiyordum ben bu
arada öysd çektim matematikten ama
matematik mühendisi olduğunu sonra
matematikten Yani hikaye Aslında
matematiğe karşı bir bilgim var ama oyun
da var ya böyle değil bu yöntem doğru
yöntem değil hani hikayede Geldiğimiz
noktada bunun eğlenceli bir hale
getirmek için şeyler atıyor şu an bile
yapıyorum yani Bak şunları kafamda kalem
dokunmadan çözmeye çalışıyorum kendimce
zorlaştırmaya çalışıyorum millete
şaşırıyordu yani çocuk sonucumu öğrenmiş
çocuğa ne oldu ne yapıyor biyolojiyi de
mesela sevmediğim için o günün tarihine
mesela ona göre seçeneklere sallıyordum
o yüzden Yıldız Teknik olarak annemler
işte ee adam gibi matematik diye hepsine
çalışsaydı daha büyük üniversitelere
giderdim falan diye rahmetli doğru ama
sevmediğimi yapmıyordum işte böyle bir
sıkıntı var yöntem doğrulamadığı için
sevdiğimde bayağı bildiğiniz
odaklanıyordum şimdi buradan bir hikaye
geçiyor Ben bu şekilde Yıldız Teknik
matematik Mühendisliği için Fethi terk
edip 95 yılında İstanbul'a gittim daha 2
sene evvel döndüm babamı kaybettiğimizde
döndüm dediğim gibi İşletmeyi almak ve
kendi işlerini devam ettirmek için ama
benim hayatımda çok önemli bir şey var
oraya gittiğimde eğitmenliği çok
seviyordum matematik çok seviyordum Ee
kodlamaya başladım yazılımla başladım ve
Turkcell akademide Ee tam zamandı bir
çalışma yöntemi oldu ve çok güzel bir
hikaye Bence bu bir tane Eğitim vardı ve
bugünkü gibi bir hava vardı çalışmıyorum
Aslında gitmeyecektim Ama bu şeye de çok
benziyor işte Birazdan anlatacağım
karium ve çeksem mi Halil'in hikayesine
benziyor Ee ya dedim ki gideyim Otel
Sonuçta ikramları vardır mesela işte
güzel vakit geçer arkadaşlar vardır diye
böyle opsiyonel deniyordu bizde işte
zorunlu olmayan bir Eğitmen için
oyunlaştırmaydı hollandalıları veriyordu
ve taksindeki bir oteldeydi Ee tahmin
edebildiğiniz gibi benim değil yüzlerce
insanın hayatını değiştiren bir karar
olmuş açıkçası ve bu hikayeyle beraber
ben oyunlaştırma ile tanıştım şimdi
oyunlaştırmayı anlatacağım ama
oyunlaştırmadan çok benzer bir hikayesi
olan oyunlaştırmanın özü olan size
bugünkü dedim ya koltuklarda
oturuyorsunuz yanınıza götüreceğiniz
hikayelerden bir hikaye soruyor sıkıcı
işleri kendimizce eğlenceli hale
getirerek çözebiliriz ikincisi
arkadaşlar akış teorisi Ben akış teorisi
sayesinde anlatmamıştım Ali abi geliyor
Baktım hani benim ailem sınıfım değil
işte böyle akademik dersler gibi
anlatmadılar ama Ee çıksam bir ailesiyle
anlatacağım Anlatacağım tek teoriyi akış
teorisi akış deyince aklınıza ne geliyor
akış teorisi Duydunuz mu hiç
Akış
akıyoruz geceleri gibi değil Biraz böyle
Aslında önemli bir konu şimdi ben sizin
yerinizde olup slow teoriyi duysam
mutlaka not alırım oyunların yaptığı şey
Çünkü birazdan söyleyeceğim size Hani
oyunlar nasıl insanların kafasını
kaldırtamıyor değil mi İşte akışa
sokuyor Siz ona Flow deniyor flow'a
girdiğinizde avlanıyormuş gibi beyniniz
kafanızı kaldırdığınızda kaybedeceğini
düşünüyorsunuz Tamam bu Bunun adı flows
10 şimdi
genç 1950'lerde Zürih Üniversitesi'nde
aynı benim gibi Genç bir çocuk ünlü bir
konferansına gitmek istiyor
arkadaşlarıyla ve diyorlar ki hava çok
soğuk gitmeyelim ve kayyum Bu arada o
konferanstan yaklaşık özellikle gittim
baktığım hikayeyi tamamlamak için tam
tamına 8 sene sonra vefat etmiş tamam mı
üniversitedeki arkadaşlar diyor ki
Dışarıda inanılmaz bir yağmur var hani
sıçramadan önce biz en iyisi şu adamda
ünlüymüş
isim kardiyum da dinlemeye Giderim Bu
Gidenlerden bir tanesi şey ediyor orada
kaynak da varmış diyor ikimiz ısınır
diyor hani Kanyak içmeye gittik Aslında
Kardo dinlemeye değil ama kar yok öyle
bir durum yok ki işte bugünkü belki bir
tane böyle aranızdan esinlenen çıksa
aranızdan Bir Hayli çeksem bir hayli
çıkabilir
ki bu arada oyun sektörünün taptığı işte
hepsinin danışmanlığını veren
oyunlardaki akış teorisi oyuncunun
yolculuğunu bulan
teorisyeni izlerken başka bir yere
gittim diyor bunun adını orada
düşünmüyorum Neydi bu diyor yani adamda
bir şey anlatıyor işte insanlar nasıl
başarabilirler insanlar bazı işler için
çok keyifli yaparken çok daha
performanslı olurken bazı işlerde Hemen
kafası dağılıyor buna bağlamaya
çalışıyor ve insanoğlunu lafta
tanıyordum aslında ne kadar
yakınlaştığımı hissettim Ama daha ne
kadar yolumuz olduğunu düşündüm diyor
Tamam Çünkü sen bir hayli pandemi de
vefat etti YouTube'da Yayınları olan bir
beyefendi bu beyefendi ak sakallı dedi
oyun sektöründe bu adamın soyadını
yazmak oyun yapmanın zorluğudur derler
böyle çok saygı duyulan çok önemli bir
karakter Şimdi ben sizden çıksam yerden
anladığımı anlatacağım teorik olarak
vereceğim tek konu bu ve insanların
oyununa çocuklara işte kızamıyorsun İşte
ben bunları anlayınca çocukları
kızamıyorsun Çünkü çok doğru bir modelle
akışa sokuluyor çocuklar oyunları
anlamanız lazım ve biz bunları eğitime
sokabiliriz işte hani şey dedi ya
Kadircan ne güzel var dedi işte
Muhammed Ali gibi satıyor ama kod
yazıyor işte oh tamam o fikir O yoksa o
test yaptırma gibi değil evet ve bu
sistemi Sizler değiştireceksiniz yani
yazık çocuk işte ufacık çocuk kalem
dokundur bana kendince bir oyun yapmaya
çalışıyor Tamam
bir aktivite odaklanıp
başarabileceğimizi görüp ilerledikçe
daha çok başarabiliriz diyor ben bu
teorik kısmı size şöyle anlatayım
yeteneklerinize görevleriniz eşleşirse O
beyaz yerlerde gidiyorsunuz Çok zor bir
görev gelirse Hani diyorsunuz ya fizik
çok zor falan değil size
kolaylaştırılmıyor hepimizin kapasitesi
Aynen veya çok kolaysa sıkılıyorsunuz
Tamam acayip oyunların başardığı şey bu
ne çok zor geliyor size ne çok kolay
geliyor bu hale getirmeniz lazım şimdi
çıksam verdiğini birkaç tane örnek var
mesela en bundan vereyim enstrümanlarda
Normalde nota yok Yani dışarıdan nota
bulamıyorsunuz ama insan olarak
başarabileceğimiz küçük Hedef bulmuşuz
bir elimize flüt aldığımızda
diye doğada Çünkü tek başına nota yok
işte notayı bulmak arkadaşlar akış oyun
sektörü başarılı şey yok Çok kritik bir
şey söylüyorum ve bunlardan firmaları
anlatıyorum işte yani eğer bir eğitim
araştırma nasıl yapacaksınız eğitimi
seçerek başlaması lazım satış oyununu
açması yapacaksanız satış önererek
keşfederek başlaması lazım Sonra melodi
karmaşık bir görev ya bu spora da
olabilirsiniz basket attırmıyorlar toplu
bir sektiriyorlar yürüyorlar Sonra
attırıyorlar işte
sonra da Senfoni şu an yaptığımız bir
Senfoni berklerin yaptığı Senfoni 4-5
kişi birlikte bir şey yapalım aynı anda
bir tane nota basamayız diye bu çıksan
bir aileyi anlatıyorum şu an size Tamam
ve oyun sektörü Aha bu doğru diyor doğru
zor görevleri kolaylaştıralım ve o
şekilde verelim daha güzeli var kelime
mesela bilgisayarların kelimeye ihtiyacı
var mı
tam konuşuyorlar değil mi boşluk
vermiyorlar niye başarabilecekleri küçük
bir görev istiyor insan Çünkü beyin
kapasitemiz kısıtlı Tamam o yüzden
kelimeler var o yüzden harfler var
yabancı bir dil öğrenmeye çalıştığınızda
önce harfle başlıyorsunuz 4 diyorsunuz
Fransız değil mi İşte başarabileceğimiz
küçük görev ne sonra nasıl
büyütebilirsiniz sonra nasıl cümleler
kurabilirsiniz değil mi Aynı Hikaye işte
Hayattaki her şeyin buna ihtiyacı var
kitapların oyunlaştırılması okumaların
oyunlaştırılması bunların hepsinde
Arkadaşlar doğru bir şekilde deneyim
tasarımı gerekiyor çünkü sen bir halin
verdiği mesaj Aslında insanlara zorla
bir şeyleri yaptırmak değil 1950'lerde
Bunları konuşmak hakikaten çok şey yani
Fabrika dönemlerinde ama insanlar bir
şeylere inanırsa başarabileceğini
düşünürse başardıkça daha fazla göreve
hazır olur bu işte aslında Ama hayatta
bir oyun oraya bağlayacağım
konusu çok önemli insanlara sadece para
puan işte takdir skor maaş terfi ile
yönetemezsiniz insanlar heyecan da
vermemiz lazım insanlara İnançla
vermeniz lazım ve Aslında koşan
atletlerin çok güzel bir sözü bu atleti
heyecanla koşar diye evet madalya
çalışır ama koşarken değil para en büyük
motivasyonumuz değil Bu yüzden bu
hikayelerde akışa sokarken parayla
sokmayacağız bizim mutlaka keşif gibi
kendini motivasyonunuz keşfetmeniz
gereken çok değerli motivasyonunuz var
hayatta bunu keşfettim bir insanı motive
etmenin Sadece parayla olamadığını
keşfettiğim bir hikaye sonra size işte
üçüncü hikaye Şu olabilir ilginç bir
hikaye işte gidiyor Şeye İstanbul'a bir
şekilde bir şirkette bir konferansa
Katılıyor Hani çeksem bir hayli gibi
çıksam Bir Hayli oyun sektörünü
değiştirdi
Ama burada da ben oynaşma kitabı yazdım
ben Hollandalı bir insana dedim ki sol
Üstteki adam veriyordu Konferansı
kırmızılı böyle Horoz gibi duran diyeyim
orası Kadıköy'de bir kafe 4 ay boyunca
Akşamları ben de buluşmayı kabul ettim
News Van derinden bakın burada İsmini
Koydum kitabımın ilk başını Çünkü
herhangi bir Türk vatandaşı ki Bence
hala yaygın değil oynaşma bilmiyordu
oynaşma anlattığım şeyleri de çok yaygın
değil hala akademik gözüken akademik
olması sıcak bir konu değil aslında
çalışabileceğiniz bir alan ama
Hollanda'da işte Bununla ilgili
İngiltere'de çok çok önemli firmalar çok
devlet kurumları bankalar var banka var
oyunlaştırma ve oyun bölümü Kuran banka
çocuk gelirse bankaya ne oyun oynatalım
Sadakat programı işte EFT yaptı Temple
Run gibi koşturalım ücretsiz yapalım
diye dertlenen böyle böyle abiler var
şimdi benim başarım sizin tarafta şöyle
bir hikaye ben bu kitabı yaptıktan sonra
bir sürü insanla tanıştım ortada
gördüğünüz her yer şu an tesla'ya
danışmanlık veriyor işte oyunlaştırma
ile ilgili Zoom yaptık o zamanlar Zoom
bu kadar popüler değil 2015 Bu arada ben
Tam zamanlı Turkcell'le çalışanım odaya
tam zamanında diyorum ya paramediğim
Artık benim inandığım bir hikaye çıkmış
oyunlaştırma Game diye bir kelime ve
insanlarla sohbetler etmeye başlamışım
araştırmalara başlamışım kaynakları
almaya başlamışım inandığım insanlarla
sohbetler etmeye başlamışım Bu dönem
benim işte bana şey denen Senin kafan
yandı dedik geri dönem çünkü hep yurt
dışındakilerle konuşuyorum ve adamlar
Yani bu ceset çok önemli oyun sektöründe
işte kitapları Art of game Eğer oyun
alanına girerseniz bu abiyi
tanıyacaksınız adam mesela kitaplarını
okuyorsun hakikaten ne güzel diyor ki;
Hayatımızın her yerinde puanlar var
diyor Maaşlar trafik puanları kredi
kartı puanları Bunlar birleşecek ve çok
yetenekli oyun tasarımcıları elinde çok
güzel deneyimler yaşayacağız diyor ve
yaşayacağız İşte bu Tamam işte hayatı
oyunlaştırmak diye geçiyor çok daha
verimli olabilir farkında olabilir doğru
kurallara uyabilirsin örnek vermek
istersek mesela ben bir şirkette
danışmanlık yaparken sağlık şirketi
dediler ki işte bütün çalışanları bütün
işte eczanelerde hizmet veriyorlar
eczaneleri bir skorlamaya koymaya
çalışıyoruz bir puan verelim değil dedim
öyle lütfen dedim fıfa'yı indirin FIFA
oynayın Bir hafta boyunca bütün
yöneticilere bir tane FIFA turnuvası
yapmalarını önerdim bu fıfa'daki radar
MEB diye geçen şey oyun sektörünü buldu
çok güçlü bir şey Messi mi Ronaldo mu
iyi olayından bağımsız kimin nesi güçlü
önemli bakın oyun sektörü çözmüş Biz
bunu Tekneyi ok eğitim sistemini
kullanıyoruz niye kurumlarda
kullanmıyoruz kullanıyoruz bak yaptık
çalıştık oturduk rozetler rozet şeyse
bakın bir müminin yapması gerekenlerinin
aldığı eğitimler raf kullanımı katedin
bu işte oynaşma hokus pokus Tamam
gelecekteki tüm çalışma platformları
okul platformları üniversite
platformları bu şekilde olacak
oyunlaştırılmış olacak Tamam ve bunun
felsefesini Siz düşüneceksiniz oyun
oynayarak daha iyisini nasıl yaparak
geliştirme Nasıl yaparız diye bizim
yapmaya çalıştığımız İşte bu benim siz
Önerim Ya sen nasıl bu kadar odaklandın
bu konuya üniversite okumadım matematik
okudum dediğim gibi yazıp o dönemlerde
annemlerimiz bu çocuk biraz matematiğe
takık deyip matematik mühendisi yazdık
Yani ilk sırada galiba İçi vardı 3'ün 4
sırada yıldız vardı girdim biz öyle
yapıyorduk o zamanlar yazıyorduk böyle
Toto oluyordu yani puanınız öğrenmeden E
ben Ama şunu motivasyonunu aldım
oyunlaştırma diye Google'a yazdım bir
konuyu öğrendiğinizde Google'a yazın
doğru content var mı Doğru içerik var mı
şu an var gururla var Genelde hocam da
burada ben bir toplulukta tek başıma
öğrettiğim yetmedi dedim ki yani bir
Ordu kurmam lazım gerçekten Ordu'da
yetmiyor bu arada da ama en azından Biz
şu an 200 kişilik bir topluluk
yönetiyorum ben ve her gün bir şeyler
yapıyoruz oyunlaştırma ile ilgili
oyunlaştırma hashta TikTok var tiktok'a
girdik oynaşma bakıyoruz kafamıza doğru
bir şey var mı orada diye oyun açma ne
yapıyor çünkü oyunu alıp size doğru bir
şekilde
gerçek hayatta oyunlaştırılmış bir
deneyim sunmaya çalışıyor Tamam bunu
yazdıktan sonra kitabın olmadığını
eğitimin olmadığını Bunlar hiçbirinin
olmadığını gördüm Türkçede oturdum
çalıştım bilmediğim bir konu yazmaya
çalıştım dediğim gibi Hollanda'da uzman
sağ olsun Turkcell'e o zaman günlük 12
bin lira fatura kesiyordu o zaman 2015
Tamam ama adam sağ olsun işte
Yemek yiyerekten yemek yiyerek sonra
bana yardımcı oldu bence Türkiye'nin bir
sorunu da bu arkadaşlar bizim biraz daha
globalle entegrasyonumuz lazım Çok Kopuz
çok Kopuz bunu bir sürü farklı nedenleri
var tabii politik siyasi ama buradan
öğrendiklerimle Evet yani ben hep şey
söylüyorum güzel bir söz O
oyunlaştırmaya benim verdiğimden daha
çok oynaşma bana verdi çok kıymetli
insanlar O yüzden tanıyorum bu çocuk
doğru anlatıyor dediler bu çocuk da o
biz biliyoruz oynaştırmaya ama yazdık
kitap doğru Bu arada ilk oynaşma ile
ilgili paylaşım yapan ben değilim
ama akademik olan aynı Emrah'ın
kapattığı gibi çeviri olmayan düzgün
kitap yazan Türkiye'ye göre yazan Türkçe
dil yazan çeviri olmayan kitap yazan
benim
Türkiye'nin en büyük tehdisi 1000
kişilik Türk kar inanma Tim Merkezi Cem
Yılmaz'ı çıktığı yer Ben mesela
provasına gittiğimde gaz atıyorlardı abi
dedim Ali abi ne yapıyorsunuz gaz
provası yapıyoruz dediler Biz de burada
provalar yaptık ama düşünün konuşmacı
değil gazın kaç saniyede ineceğini
provaeden bir etkinlik bu Tamam ve bu
etkinlikten ben değil
oyunlaştırma hiç Tetik sahnesine çıkmadı
Türkiye'de Gel Anlat Dediler ilk dedik
konuşmasını oynaştırma ile ilgili Ben
yaptım daha gurur verici hem de çok
komik gelecek size Türkiye çok değerli
bir ülke aynı İran gibi şimdi
çok değerli bir ülke İran'da da
problemler var kapalılar biraz şu an
şeyden dolayı ben Türküm dedikçe
insanlar beni davet etmeye başlar Ben
tam 22 ülkede oynarsa
gidip sunum yapıp geri dönüyorum çünkü
konferans gibi olduğu için gezme
fırsatım olamıyor Hani
o kadar yani bu ibadetlere gittiği gibi
oldu yani demo gibi ama Amerika gibi
birçok farklı ülkede sunum yaptım Neden
biliyor musunuz uzman olduğum için değil
Türk olduğum için ya Türkler oynaşmayı
nasıl yapıyor dediler Tamam gidip Bu
gördüğünüz konferansta gamepation World
diye geçiyor yaptığımız projeleri
anlattım sonra beni çok sevdiler
sıcakkanlıyım biraz Bu gördüğünüz
ekrandaki dünyanın en ünlü
oyunlaştırmacı biri Alman biri Tayvan
asıl Amerikalı ve altu listeli yani
desteklemek istiyoruz ne istiyorsun abi
gelin dedim ülkeye Hani takdir Türkiye
çok yalnız bir kez Sonuçta gelin İkisi
de geldi geldiği anda ben yüzlerce
gönüllü bulmaya başladım etrafında Yani
bu adam getirebiliyor diye adamlarla
orada tanıştım yemek yedim sohbet ettim
sonra gelin dedim ikisi de geldi Tekrar
söylüyorum fiziksel olarak
sanki lise arkadaşım gibi sohbetleri
etmeye başladım bu adamlarınızın yani
Amerika'da danışmanlık veriyor Çok
havalı adamlar yani öyle söyleyeyim ama
şimdi ilginç bir hikaye Türkiye'ye
istediğim katkıyı veremedim veremedim de
yani
bir gün babamın oteldeki ofisine geldim
ben böyle işte dediğim gibi dönem çok
fazla koştum Ziya Hoca hatırlarsınız
Milli Eğitim 2023 işte vizyonu vardı
orada 100 tane uzman çağırmıştı bir
bendim
buradan yola çıktığımızda sonra benim
toplulukla ilgili Arkadaşlar gördüğünüz
gibi bu bizim fiziksel etkinliğimiz
yukarı burada bir yerlerde diyor
hatırlıyorum fotoğrafın içinde vardır
sonra tabi İşte biz daha dün değil mi 12
Mart Aynen Dün yaptığımız etkinlik
burada işte artık online topluluk olduk
yapmaya çalışıyorum Fethiye'den elim
geldiğince oyunlaştırma ile ilgili ve bu
toplulukla beraber oyunlaştırma adına
üretmeye çalışıyorum son noktada Tabii
ki buraya geldik gelgitlerle şöyle bir
hikaye olmaya başladı bu 2015 yılından
bir hikaye Babam ve babaannem hayatta
ben o zaman İstanbul'dayım oyuna aşama
çalışıyorum kitabımı yapıyorum bu bence
zaten şey hani kapanış hikayesi olacak
geldiğim zaman babaannem Alzheimer
hastası oldum Babaannem ne yazık ki işte
beni hatırlıyor mu geriye dönük adı
unutma veya işte Yemek yedin mi deyip
bir daha yemek yemeye sonra gördüm ki
tanıyor musunuz şimdi bu Fethiye esnafı
buradakiler o meşhur
fotoğrafçı Aynen
arkadaşı Şimdi babam da Babaanneme
yardımcı olmak için evi müze gibi yapmış
böyle bizim düğünleri koymuş yani
Bak senin o küçük gördüğün o dans eden
vardı ya altı böyle erozyon tişörtü Hani
evlendi çocuk sahibi oldu böyle şeyleri
koymuş Düğünden fotoğraf koymuş Ben de
gittim Böyle eksikleri yapıyorum
kızımdan fotoğraf çıkardım Hani Bak
kızım da oldu falan diye gittim işte
yardımcı oldu bana hayatta diye
biliyorum İnşallah hayattadır Balcı
Cevdet oldu Balcı evde Babamın arkadaşı
dedemin arkadaşı galiba kapatmış
O da meşhurdur yani Balca devlette
Mesela şimdi ben bunları geldiğimde
Şurası işte telefoncu benim arkadaşım
telefoncu olmuş bir tanesi polis olmuş
buluştuk böyle sarılıyorum adamın
üniforması bozulmuş düzelttim falan
Kusura bakmayın Çünkü o benim gözümde
halaim Yani benim sizin gibi arkadaşınız
tamam mı Adam Komiser olmuş Burada
yıldızlar falan var tamam mı İşte
yukarıda ibadetin var az önce buraya
götürdüm gene ibadetini biliyorsunuz ama
babasıyla tanışıyorum bende Babamın
arkadaşı onun da babası rahmetli oldu
devam ediyor dönüp dolaşıp Geldiğimden
şunu sordular bana ya ben anlatıyorum
işte yurtdışına gidiyorum çok önemli
insanlar çok büyük destek veriyor bana
şöyle konferanslara çıkıyorum çok
heyecanlanıyorum Aferin Peki ne zaman
Fethiye'ye geliyorsun
Ne zaman geleceksin Baban ne yapıyor
yani burada büyüyen insan için hakikaten
cevaplayamadım ya Şimdilik gelmiyoruz
diyordum Tamam ama Geldim pandemiyle
fetö'ye döndüm ve bu hikaye 2015'ten
mantıklamada şey babaannemi almaya
çalıştım aslında İlacın ismi ve
babaannemin yaşadığı o dönem Hani o
dönemdeki yapmaya çalıştığım aslında
ilaçtı yani son slaytta da şöyle bir
şeyim var hayat gerçekten bir oyun yani
skorborg ne ile gidiyor derseniz parayla
değil onu söyleyebilirim belki parasıyla
yardımcı oluyordur taktik anlamında bazı
şeyler anlamında ama benim hayatımda
gördüğünüz gibi bana çok fazla yardımcı
olan oldu hiçbirine para veremedim
arkadaşlar bakın O gördüğünüz Uzmanlar
var ya işte tesla'ya danışmanlık
yapıyorlar hocamız biliyor
hiçbirine paralim sadece Türküm Diye
ihtiyacım var diye Ne diyelim Öbür dünya
skorum değilim iyilik olsun diye
yardımcı dediler ve ben yüzlerce insana
dokunabildim bu sayede bunu da
sorumluluğunu yaşıyorum üstümde sizin
hayatta bu tarz şeyleri gördüğünüzde
Hayat skorunuzda anlamlı şeyler buldum
parayla işiniz olmasın değil ama insan
Bence en çok kazanabileceğiniz şey
mesela Az önce işte bana zorladılar ben
çünkü öyle görüyorum bir insana ne
yaptırabilirim diye iyiliğinden değil
Hayat böyle çünkü ondan Nasıl para
kazanabilirim ondan nasıl bunu
yapabilirim değil de çok ciddi anlamda
da gerçekten çalışan bir sistem bu onu
söyleyebilirim tek negatif şeyi ne yazık
ki Zaman çok hızlı gidiyor bu oyunda
gözünüzü açıyorsunuz çok büyük
felaketler olmuş Gözünüz kapıyorsunuz
sevdiklerinizi kaybediyorsunuz O yüzden
hayatın Hani skorbord'un da anlamakta
fayda var tabi Şimdi ben oyunlaştırma
tarafındaki son böyle slaytımı kızıma
Bırakmak istedim Çünkü şimdi oynaşmayı
öğrenirken uygulayacak alanım yok o
zaman kurumlar çağırmıyor
Sevgili kızım da o zamanlarda küçüktü
hani uyguluyordum mesela o dönemde
koymuştum diye hatırlıyorum
şey var Bir dönem çocuklarda çok fazla
ses çıkarma oluyor böyle anne baba
olanlar bilirler ama bartlı yani hani
böyle sessiz rozeti mi öyle bir şey
yapmıştım falan rozet Yapan baya gittin
geldin eve verdim Bu akşam çalıştı
böyle kendisi burada
ertesi günüm oldu yattığı kadar özetle
kalktı falan babacığım bana çalışıyoruz
falan okula giderken çıkartıyoruz
koyarız derken gene bağırmaya başladı
rozeti duruyor burada tamam mı
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Merhaba ben Zeynep Bade 10 yaşındayım ve
5 sınıfa gidiyorum ben de her çocuk gibi
okulda dışarıda oyun oynamayı çok
seviyorum Peki sizin aklınıza oyun
denince ne geliyor benim aklıma oyun
denince üç tane bölüm geliyor bir
fiziksel oyun 2 dijital oyun Üçüncüyü de
birazdan söyleyeceğim
piksel oyun Yani birinci fiziksel
oyunlarda genelde Saklambaç yerden
yüksek ebelemece mesela her gün okulda
oynadığımız şeyler dijital oyun ise
Minecraft pubg roblox mesela arkadaşım
Vela ile oynadığımız
ve üçüncü yani babamın oyunları
bazenleri sıkıcı olabiliyor ama yine de
İşte babamın oyunları
babamın oyunları dediğimiz yani meğersem
bütün bu hayatımızda kullandığımız
oyunlar dijital oyunda fiziksel oyunlar
Aslında bunun meğersem adı
oyunlaştırmaymış Eğer bu kelime
oyunlaştırma kelimesini benden ilk kez
şu anda duyuyorsanız bu kelimeyi
hayattaki
Arkadaşlarınıza sevdiklerinize
öğrencilerinize kullanarak daha güzel
bir hayat yapabilirsiniz teşekkürler
[Alkış]
[Müzik]